hey 42 here the year is 1096 it will be
two hundred and three years until the
Ottoman Empire will begin and starts
decorating many a living room with
comfortable foot stores in 334 years the
Aztec empire will be founded and begins
sacrificing 20,000 humans a year to keep
themselves occupied and it will be 487
years until the British Empire start
taking over the world by sticking flags
in things and people yet in this year of
1096 what is today the world's oldest
university in the english-speaking world
Oxford University will teach its very
first lesson 113 years later Cambridge
University will be founded and between
them both these powerhouses of education
spanning back over a millennium have
changed the world in more ways than one
can count and definitely for the better
these two research and education
establishments are responsible for
world-changing inventions and
discoveries such as the theory of
evolution IVF artificial intelligence
heart and lung transplants stem-cell
research gravity the discovery of
electrons and nuclear fission and last
but not least the internet and those are
just a small selection so to try and
argue that the University education is a
waste of time and money would be futile
would it not well all over the world
education has changed dramatically since
the days when the inventor of the World
Wide Web Tim berners-lee studied at
Oxford University and it has even
changed over the past 15 years since
Mark Zuckerberg learned how to ruin the
world wide web with Facebook at Harvard
University university or college
education as our transatlantic cousins
call it is today less relevant than ever
before in history and for many young
people attending university could be one
of the most expensive and biggest
mistakes
they ever make aside from pre-purchasing
no man's sky all over the developed
world we have it drilled into our heads
during our school days that higher
education is two paths to gold and
riches get a college diploma they said
get a university degree they insisted
and you too will be able to afford
champagne hot tubs and the limited naked
women we get told this so frequently by
our elders because when they attended
university that was mostly true thirty
years ago if you were lucky enough to
study at university you were pretty much
guaranteed a job in your field of study
engineering graduates would go on to
work for a car or aircraft manufacturer
media students could get a job at a
Broadcasting House and so on provided
you got a decent grade your future in a
well paid job was almost guaranteed
today things have changed on average
only half of University and college
graduates get a job in the years
following graduation and I'm not even
talking about a job that has anything to
do with what they studied statistics
show that many of those 50% of employed
graduates are working in completely
unrelated menial jobs because today less
than 30 percent of all university
graduates go into work in the field of
their degree unless you took the
underwater basket-weaving degree the
demand for those things is off the
bloody charts yes that is a genuine
course the reason behind this has a lot
to do with numbers in the 50s 60s and
70s only the middle classes and affluent
families could afford to send their
little z' to university even in
the UK where university tuition fees
have only existed since 1998 it didn't
matter because to support the family
children would have to go off to work at
the age of 18 or even younger higher
education was just never an option for
most people as a result in 1950 a
pitiful 3% of people in the UK
attended university today that has risen
to 49% that's obviously a really good
thing as a society we are all now more
driven and more financially able to
attend university and educate ourselves
in any field we choose but the problem
is the number of jobs available has
hardly risen at all
with so many hundreds of thousands of
graduates each year in the UK and over
4.5 million new graduates each year in
the u.s. the competition for the
specialized high-paying jobs is greater
than ever before and if you graduated in
something more general that isn't so
specialized such as media or Business
Studies
then good luck to you my friend because
you've got an extremely tough journey
ahead of you if you currently are or
have been in this situation yourself you
will know just how horrible it feels but
if not imagine spending 2 to 6 years at
university studying hard sitting through
countless lectures with a hangover
probably and living off nothing but the
two important student food groups
instant noodles and whatever you just
found in your cupboard on toast but
finally after this seemingly longest and
hardest years of your life so far you
have a moment of glory you graduate you
throw your cap into the air and you are
filled with optimism for the fruitful
career that awaits you then six months
later you're working in a call center
still eating your typical student diet
now imagine all that but you are also
joyfully over 50,000 pounds in debt and
this exact situation is not just
befallen on a fringe group of graduates
the majority of university graduates
over 70% find themselves in a career
that they never want and almost 100
percent will be in debt for the next 30
years of their life I'm not here to say
whether universities should be free or
not because truthfully there
are incredibly strong arguments on both
sides of that fence on one hand charged
in tuition fees make students value and
appreciate the opportunity more strongly
and they tend to put more effort into
their work also without having to rely
on government handouts universities can
also offer a higher quality of education
and more resources for students but
conversely if university fees are
completely abolished a greater diversity
of people are given an opportunity to
better themselves and in the long term
it does actually pay off for the
government and for society because a
generally better educated society are
going to contribute more to the
country's economy in the future through
increased innovation and business the
shittin shake weights didn't invent
itself you know university or college
graduates are also statistically far
less likely to be involved in crime
reducing policing and prison costs and
are less likely to rely on social
welfare during their lifetime just think
about it when was the last time you saw
a doctor of theoretical physics having a
custody battle with their sister and Joe
McHale each year millions of young
people graduate from universities but a
poll recently conducted in the UK shows
that one-third of university graduates
regret going to university altogether so
what's the issue here do students just
regret how much money they've spent on
instant noodles and booze probably but
that's not the main issue whether you
paid for your tuition or not the problem
is what you're actually getting in
return for your hard spent time and
money when polled 49 percent of
graduates said that they could have
gotten the job they are currently doing
without ever attending university or
higher education the problem isn't just
a sheer number of university graduates
out there and the huge competition over
the years the true value of a university
degree has been eroded away becoming
increasingly worthless just like Windows
over recent years the percentage of
university grad
it's achieving a first or 1/1 has risen
sharply in the UK ministers have spoken
out about how they believe universities
are increasingly making it easier in
very sneaky ways for their students to
achieve higher marks so that the
establishment looks better on paper and
thus they can better compete in
university league tables and to make
things worse it's believed that in many
universities across the globe corruption
and abuse of funds is rife if the many
reports are to be believed then it's
particularly bad in u.s. higher
education surely the 50,000 plus you
borrow to attend university is put to
good use is it not it spends on hiring
the best teachers in the world
purchasing the best facilities for the
students well yes a lot of it is but
many journalists have uncovered a seedy
underbelly in many top universities many
higher up staffs such as university
presidents can earn more than CEOs of
big corporations and one really has to
think should they really be earning that
much from a nonprofit organization apart
from day-to-day management's the primary
roles of a university president is
fundraising now this involves
horrendously arduous tasks such as
wining and dining international visitors
or even jet-setting off for days at a
time for meetings how hard it must be
for them and of course university funds
are used to pay for all of these
activities universities have long been
viewed as nonprofit establishments but
journalists believe that today many
large American universities are acting
more and more like for-profit
corporations they are increasingly
engaging in patenting and licensing of
ideas concepts and innovations which
only opens up opportunities to profit
from an idea and is directly
contradictory to providing open
education for all and this is just
scratching the surface
UNESCO released a report called
schools corrupt universities what can be
done after six years of investigation
into schools and universities worldwide
the report claims that education at all
levels is corrupted with embezzlement
illegal registration fees and academic
fraud among other shady practices I'm
not trying to put anyone off higher
education for so many people it can
absolutely be the right choice and the
best thing they will ever do but if you
are turning against the idea then what
are your alternatives well unfortunately
if your dream is to be a doctor dentist
or engineer I'm afraid you will have to
attend University since they are
strictly regulated after all what do you
want to be operated on by a surgeon who
got their diploma from the University of
YouTube but those specific careers aside
the only thing stopping you from
achieving your dream job is your passion
the most important thing you can do in
your professional life is whatever makes
you happy if you're currently thinking
about your future career you may think
that by opting for a well-paid but
boring job you will have a happy life
but I promise you the day will come when
you wish you had followed your true
passion instead and if you're 30 years
down the line and you already realizes
20 years ago that I'm truly sorry my
friend but I think it's about time for
your midlife crisis I can just go ahead
and give you a list of numbers for
Porsche dealerships if you like today
with the internet the opportunities to
do what you love are limitless and
literally the only thing stopping you
from accomplishing your dreams is your
willingness to try and if you stick
around until the end of this video I'll
tell you a story that will make you want
to stop everything you're doing and
follow your dreams no matter how big
they are one of the absolute best places
on the internet to allow you to achieve
your dreams and follow your passion is
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes in design business technology
and so
much more premium membership gives you
unlimited access to high-quality classes
on must know topics so you can improve
your skills unlock new opportunities and
just do the work you love one Skillshare
course I found absolutely essential is
the writers toolkit six steps to a
successful writing habit whether your
dream is to be a novelist journalist or
even write videos like me this course
teaches you how to express your ideas
and avoid writer's block it's an
absolute must
what's so great about Skillshare is just
how affordable it is an annual
subscription is less than ten dollars a
month and for what you get
that's unbelievable value I have yet to
find a self learning platform out there
that rivals the professionalism and the
wealth of incredible knowledge you can
find on Skillshare whether you want to
realize a lifelong dream or simply start
a new side project Skillshare is a
must-have tool and since Skillshare is
sponsoring this video the first 500
people to use the promo link in the
description will get their first two
months for free so about that story I
promised you there are hundreds of rags
to riches stories and each one is
inspiring in its own way but there is
one entrepreneur who has perhaps
suffered more than any other on his
journey to success Californian John Paul
DeJoria is today worth 4 billion dollars
but not so long ago he was homeless let
me tell you exactly how that happened
DeJoria grew up in a very poor household
without a father at nine years old he
started selling newspapers just so his
mother and his brother could eat
eventually DeJoria was sent to a foster
home when his mother could no longer
support him and his brother in school
his math teacher once told him that he
would never succeed at anything in life
and DeJoria says that ever since that
moment he was determined to change his
life an interesting side note my math
teacher once told me the exact same
thing
seriously what's wrong with math
teachers also if you're watching haha
but if only things were that simple for
DeJoria because from here on out things
only got worse for him at 22 de Joie his
wife abandoned him and their
two-year-old son but not before she
drained every dime from his bank account
and took his only car it's not really my
place to say but wow what a grade-a
DeJoria was subsequently evicted
from their flat and forced to live on
the streets with his infant son he was
homeless for some time and resorted to
rummaging through bins to find empty
bottles at that time you could trade in
empty bottles at grocery stores for a
couple of cents he did this for a while
just to make money to buy food for his
son eventually DeJoria got a job as a
door-to-door salesman the job
requirements must have listed must make
a good stereotype because he sold
encyclopedias one day DeJoria decided to
start a haircare company with his friend
Paul Mitchell who was also broke
incredibly they managed to secure a
$500,000 investment from a venture
capitalist but on the day they were
supposed to launch the company the only
investor pulled out leaving them both
with nothing this fourth DeJoria to
become homeless once again he began
living out of his car so in one
last-ditch attempt to make his haircare
company a success he and his business
partner Paul Mitchell pooled all of
their money together and DeJoria asked
his mum for a loan of three hundred
dollars all of this added up to just
seven hundred dollars but it was just
enough to produce their first bottles of
shampoo they even had to print the
packaging in black-and-white because
they couldn't afford Cola according to
two zoria during the first two years
they nearly went bankrupt almost every
single day but eventually they managed
to slowly build up the business through
hard hard graft and their customer base
of salons increased after two years they
were able to finally pay their bills
and focus on growing their business
their brand John Paul Mitchell Systems
became a global success selling in 150
thousand salons all over the globe John
Paul DeJoria had everything taken from
him twice and became homeless twice
today
the man is worth four billion dollars
off the back of his success in haircare
he also started a premium tequila
company called patron spirits which he
recently sold to Bacardi for 5.1 billion
dollars now if the giorious story
doesn't give you the motivation to stick
to and pursue your dreams no matter what
then nothing will at the end of the day
whether you're university educated or
not there's only one person that can
make you successful you and it won't be
your college or university diploma that
is responsible it will be your
determination to make it happen thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
then consider clicking here to support
me on patreon it really helps out the
channel and I'd like to thank Skillshare
once again for supporting this video
don't forget to check out the promo link
in the description before it's too late
because you won't regret it